the design of the tolkun has been one of
the biggest challenges on this project
we knew we needed not only a creature
but also a character and an intelligent
species we knew the analogy was whale
but the challenge was how alien do you
get the assignment when I came on board
was to try and take a well creature and
push it this was a sketch that Jim had
started that through our process I've
just kind of helped puzzle things
together and it's been inch by inch
design
this is an occasion of of having design
had to jump through many different
storytelling needs first and foremost is
the sensor Crest it's an auditory sensor
that plays very much into the tolkun
hunt
we needed loac to be able to ride on a
fin and look high a con in the eye and
that was a challenge because having a
fin that close to the eye is kind of
weird so we ended up making a smaller
cephalic fin that is almost kind of
right behind the jaw and so this spatial
relationship was a challenge to get and
was actually defined you know in some of
the first Scouts to the Bahamas it's one
thing to design all these worlds and
characters but like how we actually
going to do this